The Frightened Lion
(A version of the tale by TheFableCottage.com)
One night, Lion is getting ready for bed.
He reads his favorite bedtime story
and sings his favorite bedtime song.
He turns on his night-light.
Then — he hears a sound...
Tap! … Tap!
"What’s that sound?” he whispers.
"That sound… it’s coming
from outside the window!”
He climbs out of bed.
He grabs a baseball bat
and tip-toes towards the window.
Tappity-tap! TAP!
“It’s a monster!” he thinks.
He grabs his bicycle helmet and
puts it on his head for protection.
He hears the sound again...
TAP! ... TAP! … Tappity-TAP!
Lion panics.
“The monster is getting closer!
It sounds like the BIGGEST,
SCARIEST monster ever!”
Tap! ... Tap! ... Tappity-tap!
TAPPITY-TAP!
TAPPITY-TAPPITY-TAPPITY…. TAP!
"EEEK!" Lion squeals.
He runs away from the window
and hides under the bed.
He pulls a blanket over his head.
He holds his baseball bat tightly
in his hands, and….
Tappity tap!
... A little frog jumps up on the window sill.
The frog is wearing a tutu and tap shoes.
She dances a little dance.
Tap tap tappity tap!
"Hello Lion! Are you in there?” says the frog.
She looks through the window
and sees Lion hiding under the bed.
Lion is wrapped in a blanket…
wearing a bicycle helmet …
... and holding a baseball bat.
He looks ridiculous.
(And to be honest, he feels ridiculous too.)
"Ummm… I have some new dance moves
to show you," says the frog.
"But you look busy.
I will come back later. See ya!"
The frog hops down to the ground
and happily dances away.
Tap-TAP! Tappity-tappity-TAP!
Moral:
Sometimes our imaginations make
things scarier than they really are.